.
>> [CHEERING].
>> Greg: HAPPY MONDAY.
IN TIMES OF CONFUSION IT HELPS
TO HAVE A LEADER DO SOMETHING
BOLD LIKE WE CAN RETURN TO
NORMAL.
LIKE WHAT YOU DAD DID EXITING
THE BATHROOM WITH A CAN OF
LYSOL.
THE GREATEST MAN IN THE HISTORY
OF THE WORLD IS BACK.
NO NOT HIM.
HIM.
OUR 44th PRESIDENT GAVE THE
MIDDLE FINGER TO THE CDC BY
INVITING PEOPLE TO HIS BIRTHDAY
PARTY.
SHOWS AMERICA THERE IS NO REASON
TO BE WORRIED ABOUT COVID OR
RISING SEA LEVELS.
CLIMATE CHANGE AND CORONAVIRUS
ARE DEAD.
MY INVITE GOT LOST IN THE MAIL
OR MIXED UP WITH THE LOVE
LETTERS FOR MEGAN FOX.
OVER 200 STAFFERS.
THE BORDER PATROL OF TEXAS IS
GREEN WITH ENVY.
IF YOU BRING A KID DO YOU GET IN
FREE LIKE THE BORDER.
PEARL JAM WAS SUPPOSED PLAY AT
THIS PARTY.
NOW THAT'S PROBABLY GOOD.
>> [SINGING]?
>> Greg: THEY ARE A THINKING
MAN'S ABBA.
ALL GUESTS WILL HAVE TO BE
TESTED.
THAT'S HOW FAUCI GOT HIS INVITE.
THIS COMES AMONG AN INCREASE
WITH DELTA VARIANT WITH A PANIC.
I SALUTE OBAMA AND THE MESSAGE
HE IS SENDING.
RATHER THAN SHUT DOWN YOUR LIVES
AGAIN.
THROW FAUCI TO THE WIND AND LIVE
YOUR LIFE.
DEATH COMES FOR ALL OF US, THE
MINUSCULE RISK FROM COVID OR THE
HUGE RISK OF BETTING MURDERED IN
PORTLAND.
TOO BAD THERE IS NOT A VACCINE
FOR CNN'S MISINFORMATION.
IT WOULD ONLY TAKE 50 DOSES.
I WONDER WHAT THE ANGRY WHITE
MALE HAS TO SAY.
>> ♪ ♪
>> LET BARACK OBAMA HAVE
A PARTY.
WHAT A MAN DECIDES TO DO IN THE
PRIVACY OF HIS OWN ISLAND
MANSION IS HIS BUSINESS.
I WOULD NOT GO TO THE PARTY EVEN
IF I WAS INVITED.
NOT BECAUSE I AM CONCERNED ABOUT
COVID, BUT YOU AM LOOKING FOR
MORE SOLITARY ACTIVITIES, LIKE
RIDING SKI LIFTS ALONE IN THE
SUMMER.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> ♪ ♪
>> [APPLAUDING].
>> Greg: YOU KNOW HE JUST DUMPED
A BODY.
WHAT ABOUT THE ANGRY BLACK MALE?
>> ♪ ♪
>> [CRUNCHING].
>> I WANT TO STICK MY HAND IN
THE CHIP BAG BUT IT'S SO BIG THE
BAG RIPS OPEN.
THAT'S NOT WHAT YOU ARE HERE
FOR.
SPEAK YOUR MIND.
>> WHAT?
>> BARACK OBAMA IS THROWING
A PARTY.
WE NEED MORE PARTIES.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS GOING TO
RALLIES WHICH ARE KIND OF LIKE
PARTIES.
THOSE ARE GREAT.
I LOVE THAT OUR FORMER
PRESIDENTS THROW PARTIES AND
RALLIES.
HOW ABOUT JUST THE FACT ONLY CDC
PARTY.
THAT WOULD BE AWESOME.
I WOULD ATTEND THAT.
THAT WOULD BE AN EASY GUEST
LIST.
AND NO FREE MONEY IS GOOD MONEY
PARTY.
THAT WOULD BE PHENOMENAL.
WE CAN ALL GET BACK TO WORK AND
PULL OUR OWN WEIGHT AND MAKE
THIS COUNTRY GREAT AGAIN.
MY FAVORITE PARTY -- YOU MUST BE
TALLER THAN 5 FOOT 9 TO RIDE
THIS RIDE PARTY.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> THERE ARE CAMERA CREWS AROUND
ME ALL THE TIME.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> KNOW IT'S YOU.
>> [APPLAUDING].
>> Greg: 5 FOOT 9.
THAT'S ABOUT RIGHT.
OTHER LEADERS ARE DOING THE SAME
THING.
THE D.C. MAYOR WAS PHOTOGRAPHED
AT A WEDDING RECEPTION AFTER
REINSTATING A MASK MANDATE.
D.C. IS AVERAGING 1 COVID DEATH
A WEEK.
THE CITY IS SO CRIMMINALLY
DANGEROUS EVEN COVID DOESN'T
WANT TO GO THERE.
IN CHICAGO, DESPITE THREATENING
NEW LOCK DOWNS THE MAYOR LOOKS
LIKE SHE JUST WALKED IN ON
A NAKED JERRY NADLER.
SHE SAW SOMETHING SHE CAN'T EVER
UNSEE.
IF ANYBODY SHOULD BE HIDING HER
FACE IT'S HER BEGIN WHAT HE'S
DONE TO CHICAGO.
ENJOY THE MUSIC.
IT DROWNS OUT THE GUNFIRE.
HEALTH EXPERTS ARE SENDING MORE
MIXED MESSAGES THAN AN MRI OF
THE PRESIDENT'S BRAIN.
I LOVE SEEING HYPOCRITES IN
ACTION.
WHAT YOU ARE SEEING IS
A DIVISION BETWEEN THE POWER AND
THE POWERLESS AND A NEW FAKE
JUSTICE ACTING LIKE ACTION.
IT USED TO THAT BE LAWS WERE FOR
EVERYONE.
NOT SO NOW.
WE HAVE LAWS AND RESTRICTIONS
FOR THE LAW ABIDING ONLY AND NO
LAWS FOR THOSE WHO DON'T.
YOU CAN COULD MANDATEED TO DO
THIS BUT NO EFFORTS ARE DIRECTED
AT THE SHOPLIFTERS OR THE
HOMELESS IN THE CITY.
WHEN THERE IS A SURGE IN CRIME
THE INSTINCT IS NOT TO GO AFTER
THE CRIMINAL WAS CREATE MORE
RESTRICTIONS FOR PEOPLE WHO
ALREADY FOLLOW THEM.
IMAGINE A FIRE ALARM THAT SPENDS
TRUCKS TO PLACESONT FIRE.
THAT'S THE NEW STRATEGY.
WITH COVID THE POWERFUL MAKE
SWEEPING JUDGMENTS ABOUT
AMERICANS WHO DON'T GET
VACCINATED AND WON'T WEAR
A MASK -- THEYED  -- THEY WOULD
NOT STAND IN THE WAY OF A MAN
WITH A BAG FULL WALKING OUT OF
THE STORE.
THEY CALL YOU NAME AND THROW
A PARTY.
IT'S THE "GUTFELD!" GOLDEN RULE.
ONE ENTERS POLITICS TO BECOME
IMMUNE TO THE LAWS ONE CREATES
FOR OTHERS.
IF OBAMA CAN PARTY SO CAN WE.
AMERICANS DO BEST:
DOING WHATEVER THE HELL YOU
WANT.
IF YOU ARE KAT WAKING UP IN OUR
NEIGHBOR'S POOL SHED.
>> YES.
>> Greg: WE HAVE MORE CATS THAN
AN UNMARRIED WHITE WOMAN.
>> [CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
>> Greg: BOSTON'S RADIO HOST
JIMMY.
>> [CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
>> Greg: SHE KNOWS HOW TO LIGHT
UP A ROOM.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR.
KAT.
HE IS CLOSE WHEN YOUR DISHES
START VIBRATING.
JIMMY, APPEAR TO BE SPLATTERED
IN COVID.
LOOKS LIKE A VIRUS VOMITED ON
YOU.
I AM GOING TO YOU FIRST.
>> YOU ARE SUPPOSED TO BE MY
FRIEND.
I LOOK LIKE A COUCH THAT SHOULD
BE COVERED IN PLASTIC.
YOU SHOULD HAVE TOLD ME THIS.
>> Greg: WHOEVER DIED IN THAT I
DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY DIED FROM.
EMBARRASSMENT.
THE HYPOCRISY ACCUSATION IS SO
OBVIOUS.
IS THERE SOMETHING MORE TO IT?
>> I LAUGH AT THE IDEA THEY WILL
HAVE A COVID COORDINATOR.
THAT'S A FANCY WAY OF SOMEONE
WHO TELLS YOU NOT TO PUT
ANYTHING ON SOCIAL MEDIA.
THEY ARE NOT COORDINATED.
THAT'S ABSURD.
AT OBAMA'S PARTY IF YOU GET SICK
YOU CAN KEEP YOUR DOCTOR.
>> Greg: A THROW BACK.
>> THIS HOUSE HAS A PRIVATE
RUNWAY.
NOBODY IS FLYING COMMERCIAL.
THEY ARE NOT REDUCING THEIR
CARBON FOOT PRINT.
THAT'S THE FRAUD OF THE WHOLE
THING.
MAYOR BOWSER WHEN SHE SAYS WE
ARE ALL IN THIS TOGETHER, IT'S
THE COCKTAIL HOUR.
THAT'S WHY WE DON'T TAKE PUBLIC
HEALTH INITIATIVES SERIOUSLY.
THE LAURIE LIGHTFOOT POINT.
COVID IS NOT IN THE TOP 20
THINGS TO CATCH THERE.
IF THEY TOLD YOU YOU CAUGHT
COVID, OH, THANK GOD.
>> Greg: THE NEW KAT, LOLLA
PALOSA IS THAT AGE GROUP.
THE ONLY DISEASE THEY ARE
SPREADING IS ARTHRITIS.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> Greg: WELCOME TO THE SHOW.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Greg: I DON'T HAVE A PROBLEM
WITH THE PARTY.
PRESIDENT OBAMA HAS ENOUGH LOVE.
DOES HE NEED TO THROW A PARTY
FOR HIMSELF?
>> HE DESERVES TO BE HAPPY AND
HAVE A GOOD TIME.
THE THING THAT FASCINATES ME IS
THAT THE WAY THAT ALL OF THIS
STUFF CAN BE TALKED ABOUT AND
EVEN THE COVID MITIGATION
MEASURES, IT'S LIKE PEOPLE ARE
FEELING THIS DELUSION WE HAVE
CONTROL OVER OUR OWN MORTALITY
THAN WE ACTUALLY DO.
IT YOU CATCH THE VIRUS AND GET
SICK IT'S NOT BECAUSE THE VIRUS
WHAT EVOLVED TO DO.
IT'S BECAUSE YOU DIDN'T TRY HARD
ENOUGH.
>> Greg: THAT'S A GOOD POINT.
I THINK THESE DAYS, WE CAN'T
UNDERSTAND COST AND BENEFIT.
WE NEED TO STAMP OUT EVERYTHING
WHICH IS IMPOSSIBLE CLEARLY.
>> YEAH, WE ARE ALL GOING TO
DIE.
SOME FASTER THAN OTHERS.
>> Greg: I HAVE MY MONEY ON YOU
BEFORE ME.
>> IT COULD HAPPEN, THAT'S THE
POINT AND I AGREE WITH YOU.
IT'S REALLY A WINDOW INTO WHY
THEY HAVE THIS ATTITUDE.
THESE POLITICIANS WHO PUT THESE
RULES IN PLACE.
IT'S NOT STAY HOME.
JUST STAY HOME LIKE IT'S NO BIG
DEAL.
THEY PUT THESE THINGS IN PLACE
DEPENDING ON WHAT WORKS FOR
THEIR OWN SOCIAL SCHEDULE.
>> Greg: IT'S NOT THAT HARD TO
DO.
WE SAID THAT ON "THE FIVE."
JUST STAY HOME ANOTHER DAY.
>> I WOULD NOT DARE.
JUST STAY HOME.
YOUR LIVELIHOOD NO BIG DEAL.
>> Greg: THAT'S VERY TRUE.
MAYOR BOWSER PUT THIS IN EFFECT
AFTER THE WEDDING.
7 A.M. SATURDAY MORNING.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> THE GIST FROM THE ANGRY BLACK
MALE.
>> I AM EXCITED I GOT INVITED.
EVERY TIME I GET ON MY
7-YEAR-OLD OR 9-YEAR-OLD TO STAY
IN SCHOOL, I CAN'T DO IT
ANYMORE.
POLITICIANS ARGUE THE SAME WAY
WE DO.
THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE TURNED INTO
NOW.
GUESS WHAT THE OTHER SIDE DID
TODAY.
THEY HAVE FUN.
OH, YEAH.
WELL YOU HAVE FUN 3 MONTHS AGO.
SERIOUSLY THAT'S WHAT WE ARE
DEALING WITH.
INSTEAD OF GIVING US INFORMATION
ABOUT COVID, BARACK OBAMA IS
THROWING A PARTY.
PRESIDENT TRUMP DID A RALLY AND
THEY WERE EXCITED AND HAPPY.
THEY DID IT ON PURPOSE.
WHAT ARE WE DOING?
RELAX.
>> Greg: IT'S CALLED FILLING
CONTENT.
>> THE ONLY PERSON WE SHOULD BE
MAD AT IS FAUCI.
>> WE NEED MORE ADULTS IN THE
ROOM.
THE PARTIES A